okay day three it's 11:23 p.m. and I'm
back from working today I was away from
the dog for most of the day look at that
eyes of pure evil actually it's kind of
adorable it's interesting the emotional
god bless you
it's interesting the emotional impact
that an animal that I've known for three
days has on me I was in a meeting at
work today and people were talking about
brief projects and problems that problem
solving solutions all of this stuff and
all I could think about it was oh the
dogs at home he's locked in a little
room in the basement I hope he has water
please don't take a [ __ ] anywhere I was
consumed with the thought of the dog
here's a funny little side note I told
these people that I was a dog owner and
I wasn't my stepmother had a dog when I
was younger I watched it being taken
care of so I figured it couldn't be that
hard but I find myself very personally
invested in this dog right now to the
point where I literally ran home from
the train station to make sure that it
wasn't dead and running at night I
realized about 3/4 into the run that it
probably looked like I was running away
from being chased which you know you
don't see so often in a suburban
neighborhood it was necessary I was
freaked out every car headlights I saw I
immediately thought this is the end
don't get in the car unless they have
Snickers